they come by the bus load a dozen times
a day hundreds of them it's a grueling
bus track from Texas to Chicago in the
American Heartland 2,000 kilomet from
the southern
border it took us 24 hours to get here
we made a few stops for the bathroom and
for food but now we're here critics say
they are Pawns in a political Feud
Republican Texas governor Greg Abbott
has transported 50,000 migrants on buses
to Sanctuary cities in the past year and
a half so far 177,000 have ended up here
in Chicago with a Democratic mayor and a
Democratic governor for many like Maria
the ride marks the end of a monthlong
journey through the perilous Darian gap
between Panama and Colombia then onto
Mexico and
Texas crime is the reason I left
Venezuela I wanted to protect my
children I had to walk through jungle in
Panama where a lot of people died it was
really hard with Texas increasing its
bus fleet from 100 to 150 the daily
buses to Chicago were expected to double
from a dozen to as many as 25
overwhelming the city already struggling
to manage its new
residents with shelters overwhelmed 2500
migrants as of today are living in and
outside of Chicago's police stations and
temperatures are dropping so the race to
get them indoors before the brutal
Midwestern winter is
on Chicago has agreed to pay $29 million
to build m massive heated tent Villages
across the city like these in New York
but here in a city with a massive
poverty problem of its own many
residents resent resources going to
their new migrant neighbors I see the
buses pulling in here every day all day
long I get off at night I see the buses
still coming in you know how do you have
other states other cities sending buses
here send them back responding to the
crisis President Joe Biden reversed
himself this week agreeing to spend more
to build new barriers along the border
New York mayor Eric Adams visited Mexico
and Ecuador and is heading to the deran
Gap our hearts are full and endless but
our resources are not Chicago mayor
Brandon Johnson plans to visit the US
Southern border soon as the long journey
comes to an end for many migrants the
city's work is just beginning John
hendin Al jazer
Chicago make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer